[Applause]
[Music]
this is the world's smallest country the
vatican city state is less than half a
square kilometer in size and home to
around 800 people one of whom is the
Pope the pontiff is not only the head of
state but is also head of the government
of the Catholic Church known as the Holy
See this institution has existed for the
best part of two millennia and
represents over 1 billion baptized
Catholics worldwide an old and secretive
entity the Holy See acts as a
surprisingly powerful player in global
diplomacy this man shapes its foreign
policy
Archbishop Paul Gallagher here are his
key strategies on running the world's
oldest diplomatic service the Holy See
is determined and remains committed to
making a contribution to how things
unfold in the world and how the relation
relations unfold between States and
people the Holy See's ambassadors known
as Knut ce o--'s represent the Pope in a
hundred and eighty-three countries and
have a permanent presence at the United
Nations here the Pope and his diplomats
Lobby other states to advance the
church's world view it argues against
abortion and contraception it also
promotes peace Nations and rulers
interacted with the Pope's over the
centuries and that has continued to
evolve and to change in in up to our
modern times
in Africa paper em boys have mediated
peace talks to end wars in Sudan Ivory
Coast and Burundi but it can also be
dangerous work in 2003 the note Co to
Burundi was assassinated by rogue rebel
gunmen for his part in negotiating a
peace deal ending the country's
decade-long Civil War Pope Francis comes
with his own particular experience of
being a Latin American being Argentinian
a pastor of a very big and important
diocese Pope Francis is the first
non-european pontiff in modern times he
was at the center of one of the biggest
diplomatic queues of this century acting
as an intermediary in talks between Cuba
and America these talks ended more than
half a century of frozen relations
between the two countries there has
always been a tendency in the church to
be focused on particular areas
Eurocentrism North American centrist ISM
I think what the Pope is trying to say
is that let's have a global vision for a
globalized world
today more than 60 million people are
displaced worldwide Pope Francis has
said that this is one of the biggest
global challenges of the 21st century
avoid Amuro kill Esperanza non-tv NTD
Luciana
Oh Pedro disparity only he believes it's
a global problem so it's something that
we've all got to shoulder in 2013 Pope
Francis called the mass downing of
migrants off the coast of the Italian
island of Lampedusa
shameful
fifteen days later Italy launched
Operation moraine Ostrom a naval mission
to rescue migrants at sea if we reject
the refugee we in some ways induce in
ourselves a certain indifference to the
humanity of suffering around us but the
Catholic Church has been condemned for
turning a blind eye to decades of human
suffering within its own institutions a
series of sexual abuse scandals around
the world Pope Francis has pledged to
address these crimes which have damaged
the church's reputation
like this here equals ENT dated Anya one
of Chicanos well
while there are calls to modernize the
Catholic Church and the way it's run
behind the scenes the Vatican remains a
powerful force in global affairs
you